2023 is a mental year isn't it we got
Council culture we're seeing everybody
getting canceled artists writers
philosophers but I'm telling you right
now I am going to draw the line when
they come for our serials
it's gonna happen Coco Pops they're
gonna be known as pops of color
Fruit Loops mental health loops
and Sugar Puffs are going to be known as
sweet homosexuals
and I've got nothing against gay people
I just don't want to put milk on them at
seven o'clock on a Monday morning
I did that joke on my tour I've broken
one of the audiences shouted out mate
what about Honey Nut Cheerios
[Laughter]
but we never cancel the things we want
to cancel do we like vegan cheese or as
I like to call it I can't believe it's
not soap
yeah it's a delight to be here but we're
all going nuts everything has become so
Progressive we're saying things that
don't make sense not people want Idris
Elba to be the next James Bond does
anybody here want Idris Elba to be the
next James Bond
yeah good few people but let me tell you
why you're wrong okay
think who James Bond is he's a man who
goes around the world causing death
destruction and Mayhem and getting away
with it the only person who could do
that is a rich white bloke who went to
Eaton
Boris Johnson would make a more
believable James Bond than Idris Elba
[__] it prince Andrew would make a model
believable James Bond in Idris Elba
because
I'll wait for his with his crimes for
years plus he's great Under Pressure
because he can't sweat
two claps mate that's what I [__]
live for
that's what I've come to do this cash
neutral gig
it's patronizing [__] off
[Applause]
but now we live in we live in weird
times we got the virtue signal now as
well that blows my mind virtue signaling
you see you I like that no laughter just
one woman going yeah
hey
but uh yeah no it's just for showing you
see oh and I'm gonna be honest with you
it's the mender of the worst it's the
mended of the worst I always go online
going you know I I hate racism I hate
sexism and they'll go on Time After Time
After Time and whenever I see these men
on social media there's always a little
bit of me that thinks to myself yeah I
bet you [__] a kid
well if you're good to hide
what have you got to hide why are you
pretending now we say things like I'm
100 anti-racist I'm 100 anti-fascist
you're meant to be your [__] idiot
that's quite literally the Baseline for
Morality
that's what me when I was when I was a
teacher going into work with a t-shirt
that said your kids are 100 safe with me
and everything's a cultural everything
is a cultural when the fact is it
doesn't need to be a culture War not the
migrant crisis that's a culture War now
you've got people on the left going oh
you know these people are weak they're
vulnerable as a society we are judged by
how we treat the vulnerable the right
are going [__] them no no no they're not
right the right guy no we need strong
borders in order to work out who is
coming into the in and out of this
country in order to keep this country
safe and people go to meet Francis what
do you think and this is what I think
genuinely right I think
if you were one of these people who
flees war and persecution
crosses continents crosses through
Europe
gets into a
towards smuggle of thousands of pounds
risking life and limb to get to this
Shore that only proves one thing France
is a [__]
[Applause]
can you imagine fleeing wall tall Aleppo
getting to France talking to a Frenchman
and going absolutely [__] not like
keep going that's it Abdul we are not
saying with these Pricks a moment
[__] longer if necessary mate I'll
[__] live in a camp on the [__]
River
I'm not talking to him
the thing he's become a cultural not the
way we talk about men the way we talk
about men is ridiculous everything is
toxically masculine everything is toxic
masculinity everything is bad we used to
worship men now we demonize men simple
things like men used to
joy and love for years like bottling
someone outside of a Weber spoke
yeah
I'm from South London Mike that's my
[__] culture
and all of a sudden Wiggles we talk
we're saying we can't do it and you know
there's women here going no Francis I
like it I prefer it now men are Kinder
they're more sensitive they listen
but let me tell you something ladies
right
when you're when we've got the
Barbarians at the gates
who do you want defending you remember
in the 2019 London Bridge terrorist
attack
do you remember that when that terrorist
was going around stabbing people he
tried to get access into a pub you know
what happened he met a millwall fan
oh
[Laughter]
he shouted the words
the millwall fan said the words are
millwall you [__]
and hit him with a chair
because sometimes ladies you need a
racist
[Applause]
I'm gonna be honest with you we never
would have lost the Afghanistan war
right if we had millwall fans in the
front row we would have shipped them
over right put them in the front line
they would have been lined up we would
have gone louder
you see that law over there no they're
not towels mate they're turbans right
you see that a lot over there yeah look
at them that look mate they're West Ham
off your [__] guy
yeah B is your thing we've still got a
little problem with racism not Mom I'm
off South American one of my cousins is
it was called it's called Johan and when
he came over to London in the 90s he
faced a little bit of racism Johann is a
really handsome man he's half Venezuelan
half Austrian tall green eyes coffee
colored skin long black hair so when he
got to London in the 90s I called him a
packet of course they did right
and that really upset me because it's
devastating to hear your own cousin
getting racially abused it breaks your
heart right because that's my culture
that's my Heritage until one day he
nicked my t-shirt and sold it
so
what I did is I took as a little Act of
Revenge I took Johan to go and watch a
mill war game
and some of you may not be aware with of
Faye with millwall fans all I'll say is
this they're very gender critical
they believe men or men and women should
shut the [__] up
and then we took him to watch the game
and we went to watch A Match and it was
all fine
and as we lift the match I noticed there
was this group of blokes right and they
started yelling the word packet my
cousin and I said to Johan I think we
better be going so we started walking
and there was this group behind us
and they started following us
and the quicker we walked the quicker
they walked and this word kept getting
used and the quicker we walked the
quicker day walks until we started
running the night started running then
we started sprinting and they started
sprinting and halfway through my cousin
knew what was going on he knew he was
getting racially abused even though he
didn't understand the words he stopped
turned around looked at the head races
and said the words
and the head races turn around looked at
his mate went [__] hell Gary this
package speaks Italian
[Laughter]
I'll leave you with this we seem to be
more divided than ever and if you've got
mate so you disagree with please please
don't push him away please don't push
him away because all it's going to do is
make us even more divided to create us
make us even more atomized because
here's the thing guys right it's really
tough in this horrible world
to be a nice kind sensitive loving
individual where we live in this [__]
up Society where things like estate
agents exist
because I'm going to be honest with you
every time I see a group of estate
agents I behave a little bit like a
racist
I'll look at them and I'll think
yeah there's too many of them around
here
they all look the same to me
look guys chill out I'm not prejudiced
some of my best mates are estate agents
all I'm saying is I wouldn't want one
marrying my daughter
because worms if they had a kid it would
come out half normal half estate agent
and we know what we call one of them
don't we a recruitment consultant
[Applause]
one recruitment consultant in I thought
I could smell cheap cocaine
there we go guys I'm only doing a short
set it's been a drawing a pleasure I've
been promises
foreign